now the uk has a new unicorn multiverse
the startup founded by sir tony blair
son ewan has been valued at 1.7 billion
dollars in its latest funding round well
the company was formed in 2016 to train
and find placements for apprentices in
the uk and the united states i'm very
pleased to say you and blair joins me
now you and welcome to you this is only
eight months on from your last funding
rand were you looking to raise more
capital
we were looking to raise more capital
but there was a huge amount of interest
in what we were doing
and as market conditions have shown at
the moment it's never a bad thing to be
able to have more capital and to be able
to invest in the programs you want to
invest in
very interesting point you make that i
mean does this in any way then reflect
unease uh on your part at the sort of
outlook for fundraising later this year
no i i think look it's it's very clear
that the the fundraising outlook is is
not necessarily smooth i think the thing
that's been important for us is if you
look at priorities for businesses and
and i speak to a lot of ceos and leaders
of businesses
diversity and digital transformation are
two of the biggest things they focus on
and the best way of addressing those
issues in tandem is through an
apprenticeship program so it's created
a renewed interest in apprenticeships
and a big focus on what we're doing
and how are you going to be putting this
capital to work
so we're going to be investing a lot
more in the depth of our programs in
ensuring for example in data analytics
you think about can become specialists
in data science in allowing someone
who's doing software engineering to be
able to pursue that over several years
of their career we're going to be
investing a lot more in our community in
the social aspects of apprenticeships
the professional networking aspects
we're going to be building out our tech
platform and our product
i mean you're obviously very passionate
about apprenticeships do you think
you're winning the argument though that
they're a valid alternative to going to
university
i think so and i look our success is
actually in many ways reflective of that
i mean we've grown
nine times over the last two years we we
launched the us last year we're now in
nine different cities we've launched
programs with google verizon cisco visa
and many others we work with over 500
employers across government tech
professional services engineering and
healthcare and that is is as much as
anything an endorsement of the fact that
more and more companies are seeing
apprenticeships is not just the best way
to to hire and attract diverse talent
but actually to develop their people as
they need to shift rapidly to to
focusing on digital data and tech as
high growth skills areas
but what about the would-be consumers of
those apprenticeships i mean if i look
at university applications last year it
was three quarters of a million i think
only about 200 000 people started
apprenticeships in this country
that's correct though the fastest
growing area is in tech and professional
services and if you think about it for
an individual
it's such a compelling proposition you
get the job you want the skills you need
one-on-one coaching you're running a
salary from day one you're not
accumulating any debt and with
multiverse you still get these these
social and networking experiences
through our community and we're seeing
an inundation of people applying for our
roles um in fact in the us we have
probably about 50 applications for every
one role and we've had 200 000
applications over the last year or so
which are the companies that you'd most
like to get on board that you haven't uh
had participating to date
i probably won't call out specific
companies but really anyone who is a big
employer in tech or professional
services we want to be working with and
actually nearly every company in the
world now because of the the shifts that
are happening in their business and
their workforce needs
has growing needs in data in digital and
tech and so it is incumbent on them to
look at using apprenticeships to create
those opportunities but also attract the
skill talent they need
and what about the valuation that you've
achieved in this latest funding round i
mean by any conventional investment
yardstick multiverse is now valued at a
colossal multiple of its sales does that
make you at all uncomfortable
no it doesn't as i said i think if
anything it's an endorsement of the fact
that people look at the world at the
moment and realize that a
one-size-fits-all model around
university or college is completely
insufficient and actually really unfair
and we've all got to make sure that the
best jobs of the next decade don't
simply go to all the same people as the
best jobs the last decade otherwise
we're building up big social problems
we're going to impact on productivity
even more and we're not going to end up
with a fair or equal society so it
doesn't benefit employers it doesn't
benefit individuals it doesn't benefit
society more widely and people have seen
in what we're doing at multiverse a
chance to make this a centerpiece of
that new movement around building an
alternative to university through
apprenticeships
who do you think you're competing with
is there much of a competitive landscape
out there
there are lots of other organizations
delivering apprenticeships many on
a much smaller scale i think i often
look at our biggest competition as
traditional colleges and universities
because for a long time they've been
able to act as the gatekeepers of a lot
of the best jobs in the labor market
with very little pushback or challenge
despite the fact there's no real
correlation between academics and job
performance so i i think for us it's
often about showing actually how this
route can be
an even better way to help people
transition fairly from full-time
education into full-time employment and
then crucially continue to develop them
because people are going to be in the in
the workforce now for at least 50 years
everyone's going to have to train and
retrain multiple times and a shot of
learning at the start of your career
through an academic institution is just
completely insufficient for what's going
to be needed and how about you
personally obviously there are all sorts
of reports this morning about the value
of your stake in the business following
this latest funding round i mean
i guess you've been in the public eye
all your life really to an extent does
it feel like there's added pressure on
you personally
i i don't think so and look it's
something she said i've dealt with a lot
of that throughout my life it's not
something i pay a huge amount of
attention to the thing i always
emphasize is the money hasn't gone to me
it's gone to multiverse and we have an
incredible team of people and leaders
who are making what we're doing happen
on a daily basis so it is about much
more than me
and i think you've got 600 employees
right now where do you think that will
be this time next year
probably come close to doubling that
we're hiring in just about every area
particularly into our tech and product
teams but also we're hiring coaches
we're hiring people into our community
team we're hiring people to work with
employers on implementing and embedding
programs so
we're continuing to grow
all right you and bled good to talk to
you this morning thanks very much indeed
thanks thank you